bonsoir je m'appelle lisa lancé sur la
scène politique
la génération z constate qu'il ya une
quête obsessive du prestige du pouvoir
et de lavaur la politique semble être
pratiquée de plus en plus par des
personnes aux moeurs légères
pourtant leur préoccupation première ne
devrait-elle pas être le peuple
alors commençons par le début
pour clore en beauté si vous souhaitez
écouter un concert de qualité
chaque musicien devra prendre le temps
d'accorder son instrument en effet pour
livrer un spectacle réussi
il est primordial que les musiciens
soient en harmonie s'écoute et se
respecte
n'est-il pas urgent de réhabiliter ces
trois valeurs au sein de la scène
politique internationale il n'y a pas
que la pollution de notre ère qui nous
préoccupe
il existe également une pollution sonore
des qui nous écoutons les nouvelles nos
oreilles sont agressés par toutes sortes
de sons discordants conflits ethniques
conflits religieux conflit politique
alors comment remédier à cette
cacophonie quotidienne j'ai une petite
idée là-dessus
celle ci risque de vous surprendre de
vous paraître original mais comme le
disait aristote il n'ya point de génie
sans grain de folie
mon rêve serait que les membres de l'onu
puisse un jour chanter ensemble
cette idée semble effectivement étrange
voire comique mais lorsqu'on compare les
qualités d'un bon choristes avec celle
voulue chez un bon dirigeant ne sont
elles pas identiques
pensez-y bien si nos ministres pouvaient
chanter ensemble
avant chaque réunion je suis fermement
convaincue qu'il y aurait moins de
tension lors de leurs échanges
pourquoi parce que le chant choral un
pouvoir immense
en plus des calmer les esprits il nous
pousse à développer certaines verte
premièrement un choriste doit savoir
écouter ses confrères pour s'ajuster à
eux et pour équilibrer le son un
politicien il ne doit-il pas savoir
écouter les demandes de son peuple et
être à l'écouté des propositions des
autres pays
les chants chorals lui apprendra
justement à mieux écouter ses pairs
deuxièmement un choriste doit respecter
les autres chanteurs car chaque voix est
unique il y a une raison pour laquelle
tel nombre de chanteurs sont des
sopranos des altos des ténors des bosses
c'est parce que chaque choriste à des
forces différentes et malgré tout
lorsqu'on combine toutes ses forces
on parvient à former des accords
parfaits
n'est ce pas la même chose au niveau des
relations internationales chaque nation
arrive avec ses différences et ses
besoins
or sans le respect des six voisins
aucune alliance véritable ne pourra
prendre forme
faire partie d'une chorale
internationale rappellerait justement à
nos dirigeants qui nous avons besoin de
nos voisins pour former quelque chose de
plus grand de plus beau
troisièmement les choristes apprennent à
respirer au même moment pour commencer
en même temps ne voulons nous pas des
dirigeants qui respire en même temps que
nous et qui respire le maire que nous à
peindre cette harmonie du souffle les
rendrait plus sensible à ce que nous
vivons et les rendrait plus humbles bref
le chant choral nous oblige à développer
des qualités essentielles qui améliorent
leurs relations humaines
il ne faut pas se le cacher
la musique a des pouvoirs inimaginable
elle brise les frontières
ces derniers mois n'étions nous pas tous
en train d'écouter la fameuse chanson
d'espoir si tôt à ce que je sache cette
chanson est chanté en espagnol langue
qui n'est pas maîtrisée de tous même si
une barrière de langue et nous divise
nous pouvons être unifiés par une seule
mélodie voilà ce que peut faire la
musique elle nous rassemble peu importe
nos différences oui je crois que nos
dirigeants prêts à co
lire de plus grandes choses s'il
chantait ensemble est régulièrement une
chanson internationale sérieusement
imaginer une centaine d'adultes debout
en train de chanter ensemble de manière
harmonieuse pour que leurs confrères qui
les suivent à la télévision ressentent
eux aussi ce respect qu'il devrait y
avoir entre chaque membre de cette
chorale internationale
et entre chaque pays le but de l'onu ne
s'est pas d'instaurer et de conserver la
paix internationale si les citoyens
pouvaient voir leurs dirigeants de boue
placé à quelques centimètres et d'un
autre dirigeant en train d'exécuter un
travail de collaboration qui demande
respect écoute et harmonie
le peuple pourra réellement croire en
des échanges beaucoup plus cordiaux
entre les nations c'est prouvé la
musique qui calme les tensions les
anciens tels que platon et aristote
enseigné que le rythme et l'harmonie
pénètre et purifie l'angle le dialogue
international n'en tire est il pas
bénéfices mon rêve c'est vrai que ce
collage devienne une vraie photo mon
rêve serait que les membres de l'onu
chante 1 mg international avant chaque
réunion importante pour signaler au
monde
quelle harmonie l'écoutent et le respect
existe bel et bien oui le chant choral
aiderait nos dirigeants à vibrer au même
diapason
car la musique à ce pouvoir de nous
affecter note par note parue elle par
parole et puis sans yoann est
n'oublions pas comme l'écrivait le
philosophe nietzsche la vie sans musique
est tout simplement une erreur une
fatigue à une m'exile merci